Good evening!
I'm Mary Ham.
And welcome to...
MEME REVIEW!!!
♪  ̶P̶e̶w̶  Ham News Intro ♪
That's right everyone,
I've taken over meme review!
*Nyehehehe*
*Nahahaha*
*hahaha*
Meme revooyoo,
YouTube's favorite show, everyone.
Let's just jump into it.
ALERT!! ALERT!! ALERT!! ALERT!!
Keanu Reves admit that he's a lonely guy and says that  "I don't have anyone in my life"
Get this man a friend!
I don't care what it takes,
someone befriend Keanu Reeves, god dammit!
Get this man some puss right now.
My man, Keanu Reeves will not suffer!
He lost his puppy, goddammit.
Is that not enough?
Now, since I'm Mary Ham,
the first male host...
on meme review.
This episode is dedicated to my guys,
my dudes,
my dudes only.
If you're a girl, or anything else...
l    e    a     v     e   !
This is me and the boys, watching spoons in the microwave (pauses) sparkling ~~
We've all been there.
And this could be you and me, Keanu,
think about it!
Me and the boys, in creative mode.
Now, this is an older meme,
but it has returned in the theme of Spider-man!
Me and the boys, in any game, with customizable characters.
This photo,
this goddamn photo of the villains in Spider-Man cartoon has gone viral!!
Oh, wow, that's totally relatable!
''Me and the boys at our boy funeral:''
This is so sad!
Everyone knows that moment.
When you and the boys are waiting for the pizza rolls to be done.
(pewds laughs)
Do you want me to say that meme one more time??
(sigh)
H e c c (burp) YRRRRRR! --YEAAHHH!
(blank)
RRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRRR
''When me the boys when one of the boys get a girlfriend:''
(sad music) It's so sad.
(LAUGHS)
These are so bad, why are these--
GODDAMNIT!! (laughs)
I'm on the side of the villains
We've all been there
Smash like if you can relate
This is so sad
Debatable but...
This is so wholesome
There's nothing like me and the boys
"There's nothing like me and the boys
"when the teacher's picking two teams for PE"
There's just nothing like it
Me and the boys
encapsulating just the best feeling
of being you with the boys
And whaman?
[Yes?]
You will never understand
[   :(   ]
You weren't even supposed to be here
Didn't I tell you to leave?
[Yes, but-]
G O !
[Nah]
This is boy special!
Boy special episode!
No women.
Alright, this one is for the girls
[YEET]
See, I bet you wish you'd leave now, didn't you
Me and the boy meme
gets a me and the boy...
Me and the moy- boy meme
Gets a gosh dang 8
Gets a gosh dang 8 point
Gets a gosh dang 8 point 5
Gets a gosh dang 8 point 5 point 20
Next.
Meme.
That actually hurts
We are sticking with a theme
of boy memes, okay?
I'm Mary Ham
the first male host of meme review
And I shall decide
what shall be done
The next meme
is another older meme
that has now gotten
a new little face make over, okay?
It's...
Well boys, we did it
Recording: Well boys, we did it
Racism is no more.
Racism is no more
thanks to the penguins in Madagascar
But they won't just stop there
okay?
All these issues,
social issues, are gone
Doo doo doo doo doo
The BOYS did it
And you wouldn't even care about that
Did I not tell you to leave?
[I'm still out here]
Why don't
homeless
people
just buy a house
Woman Locker room: I HATE PE. -CHECK OUT MINE BIKINI. - DONT WATCH AT ME.IF THERE WERE WHERE WATCH LOL I SAY THAT MY APPENDIX HURT WTF IM FAT STUPID PE.
BOYS LOCKER ROOM: